Today I want to share the best
supplements for very specific health
conditions. And I think everyone should
really know this information because
sooner or later you might end up with
one of these problems. And it'd be nice
to know a remedy that could help you,
especially if you're not into taking
drugs. Now, when people research
supplements, they have this idea that
evidence-based research is the best way
to find out if a supplement worked. This
is very misleading because when you look
at evidence-based research, you're going
to find a lot of mixed reviews. When we
get into supplements simply because
certain organizations, and I'm not going
to mention their name, will purposely do
research to invalidate the results of
natural remedies that compete with
commercial remedies that make a lot of
money. Who's going to fund a natural
remedy? It's very, very expensive to do
research. And so you're not going to see
a lot of credible research in the area
of nutrition. We have this omitted
research that people will say, well,
there's no research to say that it
works. That doesn't mean it doesn't
work. It just means that no one wanted
to pay for the research to validate if
it worked. So, what I'm going to share
with you is based on a lot of personal
experience working with a lot of people,
tens, hundreds of thousands of people
over years, and just observing what
works the majority of the time and what
doesn't work, as well as a lot of deep
diving into the mechanics of how
nutrition solves a problem. This video
is not going to be a comprehensive study
on every single health condition, but
I'm going to talk about the top health
conditions and how supplements or a
nutrient or remedy could help that
problem. Starting with probably the most
important one, which is vitamin D. One
thing you need to know about vitamin D
is that we have a lot of resistance
against absorbing vitamin D for all
sorts of reasons from the lack of sun
because we're not outside as much
depending on the season where you live
in relationship to the equator, how old
you are, how much you weigh, if you have
insulin resistance or diabetes. You can
override all these problems by just
taking more vitamin D3. you would need
to have at least 10,000 IUs to up to
50,000 IUs every day and even more than
that depending on certain circumstances.
And I've done a lot of videos on this
topic. One of the most important
conditions with an S that vitamin D can
help you with is autoimmune diseases.
Okay, the common theme of an autoimmune
condition is inflammation. So vitamin D
in the right dosage can be a very potent
anti-inflammatory. Vitamin D regulates
the immune system. In other words, if
you have a hyper immune system, vitamin
D can tone it down. And then we have
other conditions where we're lacking
immune support, and that would
definitely be something like cancer,
AIDS. Vitamin D is essential for those
conditions. Vitamin D also works great
for depression. Another condition that
you might not realize that vitamin D is
good for is gluccom. In fact, a lot of
problems with the eye can be greatly
improved with high doses of vitamin D3.
And then we have the classic low back
pain or anything related to your pelvis
like hip pain, deep bone pain, vitamin
D3 because vitamin D3 can help benign
tumors as well as cancer. Another really
great benefit of D3 is anything related
to hair loss, dermatitis. A
dermatologist would give one remedy,
vitamin D3, in high amounts. They would
get amazing results with almost every
different type of skin inflammatory
condition. And one key point about
vitamin D, anytime you take vitamin D3,
you also need to take the co-actors
magnesium and zinc and vitamin K2. All
right, the next supplement I'm going to
recommend is magnesium glycinate. I
don't recommend other forms of magnesium
too much, especially because the
absorption is not that great. So, what
is magnesium good for? Well, allowing
vitamin D to work. They both work
together. You could actually take
vitamin D and be severely magnesium
deficient and not see any of the results
from vitamin D. The same thing goes with
magnesium if you're taking magnesium
without vitamin D3.
Magnesium will only work to a certain
degree. And anytime you take either
magnesium by itself or vitamin D by
itself and then develop side effects,
it's usually because you're deficient in
the other co-actor. There's a lot of
body conditions that occur in the early
morning because of a deficiency of
magnesium. Because magnesium kind of
goes on this wave and you're going to
hit the lowest point in the early
morning, maybe about between 5 a.m. 6:00
a.m. 7 a.m. What kind of problems occur
more in the morning? A lot of problems.
Cramps in the legs, cramps in the foot,
increased risk of heart attacks,
clotting happens more in the morning,
strokes happen in the morning, even the
dawn phenomena, which is the higher
blood sugars occur in the early morning.
All of that means you need magnesium.
Migraine headaches, magnesium, but you
need higher amounts. If you're taking
like 400 milligrams, you'll see the
results. But with migraines, sometimes
you need to take 800 to a,000 or even
more milligrams of magnesium to create
the effect with migraines, depending on
how bad they are. Also, magnesium lowers
cortisol and adrenaline. That's why it's
good for sleep. Magnesium also helps
thin the blood and helps prevent
clotting. Magnesium is good for blood
pressure, good for anti- clotting
effects, good to prevent cramping of
muscle, but magnesium is really good as
an electrolyte to prevent arrhythmias as
an atrial fibrillation. So that's
another really important heart effect.
Magnesium is also at the heart of making
energy. So anything related to chronic
fatigue, a loss of energy in the
mitochondria, magnesium is the answer.
Especially if you're exercising and you
just don't have that endurance, you need
magnesium. The way that I know that I
have enough magnesium is all of the
muscles in my body are calm and not
tight. This last point is magnesium to
prevent kidney stones. This is a huge
reason why people have kidney stones is
magnesium deficient. Next is betane
hydrochloride that should be taken
anytime you have heartburn or
indigestion. Betain hydrochloride gives
the stomach more acidification. Okay,
more acid. Most of this is a lack of
acid and also the valve just doesn't
close because there's a lack of acid.
What betain kychloride does is help you
keep that top valve closed giving you
more acid so you can digest better.
Sometimes you have to take three or four
or five or six or seven before a meal to
get it to work because it's not like
highly concentrated. Next remedy is zinc
carnosine. Hands down the best remedy
for an ulcer in your stomach and it
helps calm down gastritis. Now, next
remedy is selenium. Okay, selenium,
believe it or not, is really good if you
have AIDS. Selenium seems to fix certain
tea cells that will then help counter
this AIDS situation because AIDS is
really an acquired immuno deficiency
syndrome. So basically, you don't have
an immune system anymore. you lost the
quarterback of the immune system. So
selenium is very very important in that.
You can get a good amount of selenium
just from one Brazil nut a day. Selenium
is also good to lower getting this
autoimmune condition called Hashimoto's.
If you have Hashimoto's, which is an
autoimmune thyroid problem, you need
selenium. So when you think selenium,
think Hashimoto's and AIDS. Next remedy
is vitamin B1. Here's another
interesting thing. You need magnesium as
a co-actor to allow B1 to work. So, if
you take B1 and it doesn't work, it
could mean that you just need magnesium.
B1 is an amazing remedy for nervous
tension, worry, stress, anxiety,
restless leg syndrome. Restless leg
syndrome, you take magnesium and B1 and
you're almost guaranteed to get rid of
that condition. Then we also have
another type of B1 that's made in a fat
soluble form called benotamine.
Bphotamine is really good for anything
with nerves in the the peripheral part
of the body in the bottom of the feet,
the toes, and the hands. You take four
pills through the day. Just keep it in
your body and that condition will
improve. Another supplement is calcium
lactate for chronic coughing, but I
normally do not recommend any calcium
supplements other than if it's just a
small amount. But you don't want large
amounts of calcium over 1,000, 1,200,
1,500 milligs because it's going to put
you at risk for heart problems. And I
recommend that you get your calcium from
your food like cheese, vegetables,
sardines with the bones in it, but not
as a supplement. Same thing with iron. I
don't recommend you taking an iron
supplement. I'd rather you get it from
food, red meat, liver, or take liver
pills. That's good for low blood
pressure, but it's also good for energy.
I also recommend potassium for people
that are salt sensitive. They're told to
lower their salt. I recommend you just
increase your potassium. But the thing
about potassium is that we need so much
of it. We need 4700 milligrams. I don't
know of anyone getting that much. The
next supplements, co-enzyme Q10. If
anyone's on a statin, they better be on
co-enzyme Q10 because a statin, which
blocks cholesterol, will deplete you of
co-enzyme Q10. What about vitamin E?
There's two different forms of vitamin
E. I recommend the toatrrenals one
because it works 50 times stronger. And
tootatrinals are really good to prevent
fibrosis. It's also good for angina,
chest pain. It's good to support the
inner layer of the arteries to prevent
plaquing. It's also good for
infertility. Next supplement is one of
my favorites. It's called Tutka. The
Tutka is a very specialized type of bile
salt. A lot of people have a problem
with thickened bile and it creates
pressure and causes pain that radiates
to the right shoulder up to the neck.
Tuta will just like make that go away.
Tuta is also good for neurological
problems in your brain. It does a lot,
but I have separate videos on that.
Let's talk about iodine. Great for
fibrocystic breast. That's an excess
amount of estrogen that's causing those
cyst. And iodine is a natural inhibitor
or regulator of excess estrogen. So
iodine is great for that. Vitamin C is
good for collagen, especially for
bleeding gums. You're brushing your
teeth and it's like turns pink cuz
you're bleeding easily cuz your gums are
inflamed. You need vitamin C.
Probiotics. If someone's on a lot of
diet soda, they're going to really mess
up their gut and they need to get off
the artificial sweeteners. Biotin, good
for hair, nails, and skin, especially to
make your hair and nails grow.
Manganese, good for Tourettes and ticks.
NAC is a wonderful supplement if you've
accidentally taken too much Tylenol.
It's really good for anything poisonous
to the liver. Snake bites, poisonous
mushrooms, think NAC and milk thistle.
Mastic gum is good for gastritis. If
you've tried a lot of different
supplements for your sleep and it hasn't
worked, I recommend melatonin for some
people. tends to help a lot of people
and it does a lot of other things which
I'll have to do a video on, but I
recommend that for severe sleep problems
that you've tried everything and
nothing's worked. Niacin really good for
anything related to cholesterol and I
recommend taking higher amounts of it.
500 milligrams, 1,000, work up to it.
You will have a flush response and
that's normal, but you want the one with
the flush. Clove oil, great for any like
pain in your teeth or gums. Now, of
course, I can go on and on and on and
on, but this is a fairly long video. I
think you've learned the most important
effects of certain supplements. If you
want all this in a quick download, okay,
I put the link down below. Check it out.
Go ahead and download it and use it when
you need it.